[Music]
if you or someone you know has been
diagnosed with high cholesterol it's
important to keep it under control
this video demonstrates a few ways to
help you manage your cholesterol such as
diet exercise and medication if your
cholesterol levels are too high it's
important to eat a heart-healthy diet to
eat a heart-healthy diet you need to
understand how the types of fats you eat
can affect your cholesterol level for
example saturated fats hydrogenated fats
and trans fats tend to raise the bad
cholesterol also called low-density
lipoprotein or LDL cholesterol in your
blood
these fats are found in meat and dairy
products tropical oils and many
processed foods such as cakes and
cookies replacing saturated fats with
unsaturated fats may help lower the bad
cholesterol in your blood when eaten as
part of a heart-healthy diet unsaturated
fats include polyunsaturated and
monounsaturated fats and are found in
foods such as salmon avocados nuts and
olive oils
heart-healthy lifestyle decisions you
can make are to stop smoking and get
adequate moderate intensity aerobic
exercise walking biking or swimming 30
minutes a day five days a week maybe a
good exercise goal talk to your doctor
about the type of diet and exercise
plans most appropriate for your health
and cholesterol levels
if lifestyle changes can't reduce your
cholesterol levels enough your doctor
may prescribe certain medications to
reduce it statins are the most common
medication for lowering LDL or bad
cholesterol by reducing the amount made
in your liver
however they have modest effects on
lowering another type of fat in your
blood called triglycerides and raising
good cholesterol also called
high-density lipoprotein or HDL
cholesterol your liver uses cholesterol
to make a substance called bile which
helps digest your food bile acid binding
drugs bind to bile and prevent it from
being used in digestion this causes the
liver to use more cholesterol to make
more bile thereby decreasing the amount
of cholesterol in your bloodstream
cholesterol absorption inhibitors block
some of the cholesterol taken up by your
intestines from the food you eat
fibrates
are mainly used to reduce triglyceride
levels in your blood but they can also
raise HDL levels niacin reduces LDL
cholesterol and triglycerides and
increases HDL cholesterol made in your
liver
healthy lifestyle habits are important
in controlling your cholesterol levels
if your healthcare provider prescribed
medication to treat your high
cholesterol it is important to take it
as directed and contact him or her if
you have any questions